We need to read the title.
No, we don't.
Very good.
All in favor?
Aye.
Opposed?
Abstention?
Motion carries.
5-0.
Public hearing.
Be.
Public hearing to consider master application number 25123.
Zoning code amendment number 2506.
Amending chapters 9.148 and 9.240.
Title IX planning and zoning to add bus dispatch facility as permitted use with the CUP and
the MSC zone and development standards.
Applicant Leslie Starks.
We will go ahead and ask for a staff report.
I know we're going to continue this item.
So I don't know if we really need to hear it.
Yes.
Good evening council members.
It's up to the council.
If you want to presentation.
We're going to hold on the report.
Let me open up the public hearing.
If we're not going to vote on it today.
No.
I'd vote to vote.
Public hearing is open.
Are there any members of the public wishing to speak online or in person?
No.
All right.
The request to action is that we motion to continue the public hearing to August 20th, 2026.
Do I have a motion?
Are you?
Yeah.
Sure.
Second.
You're the motion.
You're the second.
All in favor?
Aye.
Opposed?
Stention?
Motion carries.
That will be continued.
Okay.
Council business presentation and discussion of affordable housing development incentives.
Housing manager Curtis Miller.